You don't know if this is just
more bullshit. It's like in a,
like you were saying earlier, if they
get you and you buy into it, hook,
line and sinker, they win. If
they get you to think, well,
how much else is bullshit?
They still went, Yup.
Because you're looking at everything
with sort of this tainted lens now
everything seemed and the sense that's
probably the ultimate goal is to disrupt
our social media environment
and to sort of hijack the,
the natural conversations
that are taking place.
Yeah. And I think it's, I mean, it's
effective. There's certain, you know,
I was in Estonia last year,
um,
and they've been targeted by
this stuff for decades now.
A 25% Russian speaking population.
And most of the news that they get is
from Russian media. Right. You know,
right on the border.
Um,
they talk a lot about the
extreme commitment to educating
their citizens to make
them realize that this
kind of thing does happen.
This is what it usually looks like.
Um, don't share it here. You know,
just ignore it.
Let it go by.
And I don't think we're quite there yet.
I think that there's still plenty of
people in the country who don't believe it
happened.
Um,
or for some reason are completely
incapable of separating the Russian social
media influence campaign happened from
it means Donald Trump's election is a
legitimate, or it means
Donald Trump colluded, right?
Those are very different statements that
you don't have to collude in order for
someone somewhere to unsolicited
go and support your candidacy.
So you can believe two
things simultaneously,
one that Trump did not collude and that
his election is perfectly legitimate and
that this had no impact and to that it
still happened. And that I think is, um,
I am consistently amazed when I read
my social media mentions it at how hard
that ability to hold those
two ideas is for, for people.
They just believe that if
they're supporters of Trump,
they absolutely cannot acknowledge
that this operation took place.
And I, or if they are passionate
supporters of the far left.
Um, it's more of like an
equivocation, you know, well,
we don't really know if they did it well.
The rest does bad things too well.
How do we know? You know,
so that's where, um, it, it,
it plays out very differently depending
on which part of the political spectrum
you sit on.
Well,
it falls right into are the issue that
we have with cognitive dissonance.
We believe in someone or
if we want someone to win,
especially if it's our team or our person
or on our side, you know, like I, I,
yeah,
I saw a lot of this when Donna Brazil
released her book detailing how the DNC
sort of rig the primaries against Bernie
Sanders and, and, and for Clinton,
there was so many people that were Clinton
supporters that just didn't want to
believe it. I was like, well,
why wouldn't you believe woman?
Like you believed her before when she
was supporting Clinton and then when she
leaves now you're now, you won't believe
her. It's because it's inconvenient.
And we were real weird in our binary view.
We want things to be good or
bad is one or zero. This is it.
And this is a super complex issue.
It seems like they've been doing this
for a long time and they've gotten really
sophisticated at it.
And I think there's a lot of people that
have been sucked into it that have no
idea that it's actually
influenced the way they've,
they've formed their own opinions.
This is where it gets really strange.
People are so malleable and
they're so easily manipulated.
Many people are that something like this,
like a real good solid,
concentrated effort to try to target
these groups that have these very specific
interests and really dig in and
form roots and then go home.
I mean, it's so sophisticated.
They're their approaches.
I'm on one hand horrified and the
other hand deeply impressed. Yep.
Me Too.
Now what was this freaking you out when
you had to like go over all these memes
and you were actually laughing at
them and you're like, God dammit.
Well, you know, there's the tweet
that goes around every now and then.
You don't have to hand it to them.
And I'm always like, ah, how do I, um,
how do I properly convey, uh, um,
recognition for the, you know, I,
I don't think we do ourselves any favors
by pretending it all sucked and didn't
matter in there and competent.
Right.
I think that you have to acknowledge that
you have this sophisticated adversary
that is very capable. Those
very determined that is
constantly evolving. Um,
and to treat that with the
degree of respect it deserves.
I think that that's just
common sense actually. Um, I,
I, I read media on both sides of
the aisle and I, I, you know, um,
I feel I try to stay current actually
on what memes are percolating in lots of
different spaces and part just because
I am always curious about what's organic
versus what seems to be disproportionately
amplified or what new communities are
popping up.
I just think it's an,
I think the spread of information among
people is just a very interesting,
you know, it's, it, it's
something that interest me a lot.
I think crowd psychology
is really interesting.
I think ways that crowd psychology has
transformed as the Internet has kind of
come into being,
particularly with things
like the mass consolidation,
the ease with which we can target people.
You know,
we didn't even really talk about that,
but the, um, one of the things with,
there's always, you know, even
in a decentralized internet,
there's always been propaganda.
There's always been, um,
crazy conspiracy theories,
all this stuff.
But it's that you can reach the people
who are likely to be receptive to it now.
And as people self select into tribes,
particularly in this country right now.
Um,
one of the things that's remarkable
is the way in which once you've self
selected into that tribe and this is
the media in your ecosystem and share it
with your friends.
And Facebook ensures that the people
who see it are the people who are most
likely to be receptive to it. Where if
you run the ad targeting you directly,
you know, send it into the feeds of
people most likely to be receptive to it.
We have this interesting phenomenon where
consolidation targeting and then these
gainable algorithms mean that it's
just this kind of information goes way
farther, way faster than it
ever could have in the past,
regardless of whether it's.